Dean and Sam Winchester Moulder and
Scully Wednesday and thing every
Supernatural crime solver needs a
partner to back them up when the back is
against the wall and it turns out that
being a disembodied hand comes in well
handy quite frequently it also turns out
that it was an impressive feat to
capture the effect on film keep watching
to find out how they did it though
Wednesday Adams did not intend on
careening down a rabbit hole when she
first enrolled in Nevermore Academy
Fates had other plans the events of
Wednesday kick off upon the titular
character's immediate expulsion from my
score Morticia and Gomez Adams ship her
off to where she can be among her peers
at school for bizarre adolescence
Wednesday fully intends on continuing
her anti-social ways thus this all
changes when she sees a fellow student
murdered by a strange monster with the
help of a childhood assistant Wednesday
is on the case at first things
contribution is slightly unwilling as
Wednesday treats him like an
insubordinate employee but after a Time
Wednesday's walls fall all and they
become true allies fans of the Tim
Burton series quickly became enamored
with thing taking to social media to
praise Wednesday's helpful and
empathetic friend one Reddit user wrote
thing is brilliant I love that Wednesday
houses one part of our family with her
so she's never really alone Wednesday
may be a modernized version of the
popular franchise but the Netflix series
still involves the classic Hallmarks of
the light fans it isn't long after
Wednesday settles into school that she
discovers she isn't alone thing first
follows her at the behest of her parents
but soon joins her wild Crusade with his
handsy skills it may seem that the seven
appendage is only the result of computer
Graphics but that would be doing The Man
Behind the hand to Victor Doro bonsu a
disservice Netflix revealed on Twitter
that thing is portrayed by Dora bonsu
who wears a full-bodied blue suits to
get the effect with his many scenes
getting into hard to reach places the
actor must Contours and many times crawl
on the ground to get the shots needed
Dora bonsu even shared a video on his
first on Instagram about the process of
filming one specific underwater scene
while these efforts may seem tedious
there is no doubt that It ultimately
gets results Wednesday would never be
one to admit it but she needs thing her
anti-social stick only gets us so far
and thing represents a support system
that never judges her from sneaking her
into morgs to getting her addressed for
the dance think has proven his Devotion
to his spooky mistress making him one of
the most likable characters in Wednesday
Victor durabonsu's behind the scenes
photos as thing have taken the Internet
by storm with many praising the actor
for his difficult role SNL Alum Lorraine
Newman took to Twitter in ore saying I'm
sincerely marveling at the actor playing
thing on Netflix as Wednesday Victor
abonsu's work is stunning with the door
bonsu on everyone's mind one can't help
but wonder who is he in the wake of
things popularity durabonsu discussed
his Wednesday role in a candid chat with
Vanity Fair the 25 year old magician had
this to say about the viral behind the
scenes photos I didn't know he had so
many photos of me behind the scenes it's
kind of interesting to see that even for
me would fans believe that Wednesday is
the robansu's first acting gig a
close-up magician by trade in his native
Romania dorobansu ended up at a casting
house in Bucharest where he was chosen
as a finalist for the role amongst two
other magicians what nubbed in the role
the magician has no idea the actor told
the outlet I wish that Tim Burton would
tell me what he saw in me what the
trickster does know is that he and the
series Creator got along swimmingly
recounting hours ham began to take on a
life of its own on a table or chatting
with Burton for the first time he said
so I guess Tim saw in front of him an
actor and the Hand separately so it was
a connection from the first moment
[Music]